all right we'll give you a choice you
can either have mario hezonia or this
horse we'll take the horse when people
ask you what happened here tell them
King James still rules the east also
tell them I'm better than Michael Jordan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
someone's coming
hey what a free-agent come into house
Hornets we have to blow the Charlotte
horn we have to blow the shawl at all
wait there's no rider it's just the
horse how did you
is there any defense in this realm
anymore you said what it's meat pie
[Music]
hey guys we meet LeBron
oh yeah thank you hey guys guys hey guys
hey everyone so glad you all could be
here I just figured since so many of you
summer in Los Angeles anyway it would be
fun to invite everyone over to my new
brentwood castle for some mingling some
pampering a little tampering but before
we dig into our delicious fastfire dort
is no place meat pies I do have some big
news Ben Simmons hit a three-pointer I
did I did
oh speaking of which my servant I mean
my lord commanders have informed me that
the pies are ready so everybody say it
with me it's time for me so you think
invented meat pie Mondays she should
call it maize meat pies cause he's so
cool
Oh Kairi I must ask you what are those
oh yes these are the new Kyrie 5 boots
in honor of sir sponge Robert square
tunic oh so creative you're such an
artist
hey how's grumpy boys so you're on
Brooklyn now eh indeed we are oh I love
it
such a good fit great young call for you
to demoralize Oh Alex Caruso's here
excuse me gentlemen
oh hey Carmelo uh uh sir new with you oh
you know got a lot of irons in the fire
oh yes uh house is showing interest no I
mean I'm actually a blacksmith now oh
well you know I for one think you've
been treated so unfairly by all those
blog boy media folk analytics people a
night of your caliber you sir should be
on a house it's ridiculous oh thank you
well you know if you need anyone I'm I
mean yeah problem with the house nets is
that with the Cap'n all's yeah but have
you talked to Dame I think house blazes
might be desperate might be interested
in the night of your caliber okay
Oh sir Jason and sir Jalen how are
things
well you know it's never easy when you
lose your best night no it's tough to
see al horford on how sixes
hey girl tip guys um so I was wondering
if it is possible for me to borrow these
Sol bucks you see for I have a new
teammate and he is a bit um sorry James
Gordon Hayward smashed it it's a long
story
oh wow okay what even happens when you
smash a soul box hey LeBron just want to
say thank you so much for having us Paul
and I had a blah you guys leaving no
we're just about to start a big 1k
tournament oh I'd love to but actually
played the game yesterday and you know
I'm trying to manage me load understood
well so glad you guys could come and so
excited for this little crosstown
rivalry remember guys the only beef here
is in the pies all right
[Music]
your generation is soft if your load
management of your analytics new AAA you
shoot the houses the gods of this game
not stand for this a reckoning is coming
caribou is look weirdly over-sexualized
those whatever brawny Judah who's
getting along
what's going on with Dion over there
okay I think he might in my special pie
oh damn it junior I just don't
understand why would I leave this place
it's good Fred what do you mean it's
good Kawai showed us the way showed us
what it takes
now it's our north me you oh gee the
rest we show the realm we're more than
just a cloth what
[Music]
Kawai without you
hello I think it's a Fanning you want us
to sign your ball
Oh
hello old friend Sugoi welcome to the
mediator thank you so delighted to be
teammates again mark was renewed you
will man down without chalk wait what
twist Sir Charles he's like the funniest
guy on the show
I mean well well luckily I'm ready to go
I've actually prepared a bit it's called
Wade's grains you see a note on truth
you can't be on the show until you've
earned your prospers Press Pass well how
do I get a press pass your audition in
audition I'm Dwayne Wade don't worry
they make it easy on X nights you just
do quick apprenticeship and then present
your findings to the other boosters you
don't be reporting on an injury
apprentice to mr. mark Stein in his
investigation of an injury tour to a
horse oh I get it you're being funny
[Music]
for full mzl tears for full ACL tears
for full Achilles tears and a fool and
neck tear
looks like the horse will be out
indefinitely
so what happened foul play my working
theory is that Robin Lopez mistook him
for mascot I've seen that mark before my
Squire season I think yes it's hand
checking no hand checking
don't be silly Duane those banned years
ago what was this horse doing when it
got hurt most things I assume take the
support of the Raven ray and make haste
I don't want to get scooped oh um excuse
me yeah Meister win horse ah sir Duane
I'm supposed to take this to the Raven
Reed do you know where that is I do I'm
going there now come poor thing
yeah tell me about it a future
hall-of-famer serving as an errand boy
to mark Stein
I meant the horse Alton definitely seems
he paid a heavy price for speaking ill
of his Airness where did you hear that
my little birds are everywhere yeah well
mostly around the Brawn but some other
places too have your little birds told
you anything else about this horse I
noticed a strange mob
since the whole sin jury my birds from
Toronto have become useless they're just
repeating the same things over and over
what kind of things
oh how nights these days are soft how
the 90s were the best how sir Jordan is
the goat boring old man stuff really
boring you could it be related to the
soul box hmm
I didn't think to make that connection
but then again I didn't have your
instincts I never played the game you
never played now everything I learned
about basketball I learned in here
so many books all the stories records
recaps bucks schools and even memes they
all live here we are this world's memory
Dwayne without us the histories and
legends of our realm would all vanish
like James Harden in a meaningful
playoff game some say if it's nothing
here it never happened
now if you'll excuse me for one moment
when I need to grab a book but I can't
come in I'm afraid this is very
sensitive information only maesters with
a press pass can enter hello Dwayne sir
Paul
there is no more Paul there is only the
truth right now that I'm in the media I
seal I know all and yes I am better than
you
I have to go now see all right let's go
well this looks like a nice place to
have a long-form intimate conversation
about basketball
yes here is where we do our pond guess
and here we are welcome to The Raven
room this is where the media and
families connect or some say even merge
the network of platforms you see
represent the various localities that
make up the greatest social media Dell a
never-ending conversation between
Fanning's scribes and knights you see
until very recently only those cloaked
in media Dell chains could reach all
corners of borås but they're longer so
what do you have for me I have this
injury report I'd like to send out for a
mr. Stein how do I out indefinitely I
broke that ten minutes ago windows what
about you another story about LeBron
those were different times this is a
story about how Luca Dunwich is an extra
bran
generations of non-fundamental windows
look looks like it's not just my Ravens
Seven Hills is going on tour I'm Terry
right well whatever it is seems um
spread train we've got to get the crane
sitting I agree
oh wait my audition it's tomorrow
night's don't worry I'll get us there in
no time for I am as fast as the inland
I'll rip your bloody antlers off Bobby
come on brough is supposed to be played
wrestling you know this bastard trick to
be deciding a giant fake contract
I asked that you be stormy day gift of
French please Jesus Shuttlesworth be
honest come quickly or being attacked is
some sort of scheduling mistake I didn't
dig do is a bathroom today
we chose look there's Yanis
this generation is soft Jordan is the
goat LeBron is weak
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to a very special
edition of inside the realm dears
masters of the media tell I now present
the audition of SERT Wayne Wade for
consideration of press credentials today
sir Duane will be reporting on the
horse's injury Duane how will this
affect house Raptors it's bad it's it's
very bad um to shame he was there glue
guy no more than over wait wait wait I'm
not done
the reason it's bad is because sir
Jordan and the entire dream team are
back and they're going to destroy our
realm one house at a time what are you
doing just wrap it up listen no Jordan
slander here but he's too old father
time is undefeated I must be real the
only return shocks making is to the
buffet table yes but that's the thing
they're all back in their primes this is
demonstrably preposterous how could that
possibly be conceivable the soul box Oh
hooey my report ensure that the soul box
was smashed in bostonia yeah that was a
tap nineteen moment in bostonia
basketball history and therefore
basketball history the soul box power is
not in the box it's in the shards that
was just a normal fault
no the shards the fragments of the
shattered soul box
they're made from the wood of Val makers
original peach baskets hickory Georgian
hardwood its GH Oh Jordan must have
gotten the shots in the terry rozier
trade that's why he paid so much
Oh hui Brian I call shenanigans where's
your proof mama there goes that man
horse how's this for evidence Wally
Szczerbiak no can't be why not because
I'm Wally Szczerbiak I think that's Tom
Gugliotta no I'm Tom Gugliotta no you're
not you're Bobbie Sora Oh
yeah it's christian laettner bang so
you're telling me the dream team is back
I mean I don't see the problem this is a
story at a century yes but it would be
the last story sir Jordan seeks to
permanently end the debate to prove he
is the goat of goats he's coming for me
no Paul truth if anyone he's coming for
LeBron hey it's my bid the people of
every city he conquers are turned into
mindless nostalgic s' with no passion
for the modern game Toronto is already
gone as is me love walkie also Detroit
and Chicago is all right no you know we
need to form a kin war it's no use
there's not a house in this realm that
could beat the dream team you're right
that's why we've got to build one ladies
and gentlemen of the media tell we're
going to need your all run ballots a
little early this year
thank you everyone for being here at
this emergency realm all hands by now
you should all be familiar with the
threat facing our realm so without
further ado I will announce the members
of the super super house hereby known as
the knights of the round ball as
selected by the maesters of the media
delle cose a blog board as president of
the knights killed i think this decision
should be made by us the Knights of the
realm I don't know if that's a wise idea
this is not the time of your this is the
era of night empowerment let us vote or
we shall fight your battles ok fine
but please take this seriously ok that's
another vote for Jamal Crawford she's
with another vote for Mello another vote
for Vince Carter who's 42 cool actually
43 now look all three Plumlee's and
Jamal Crawford again look if you're not
going to take this serious I took it
seriously you voted for Allen Iverson he
cannot even play anymore
how you gonna disrespect Iverson like
that one of you even voted for Michael
Jordan hey so Jordan was unstoppable in
his prime yes we know that's the whole
point we have to defeat him well good
luck with that maybe we should let the
fatlings vote
oh okay listen we experimented with
letting the fatlings vote for the final
roster spots let's just say it was a
mistake well who do they pick takaful oh
okay buddy you still my little goat and
while we all agree we love taco we can
also all agree we do not want taco
defending the realm against the dream
team so you'll just go to disrespect
talker like that Wow okay taco do you
want to go against the dream team not
particularly right thank you
you may sit down oh absolutely dude
listen this is not just any battle if we
lose our fan Ling's will desert us our
economy will screech to a halt and our
society which is solely based on
interest in basketball will crumble
around us before you know it we'll be on
the verge of extinction like the ice
peoples of our Kenya so here are the
official media delft selections for the
knights of the round ball King James sir
who del Stefan carry the second Sir
Anthony Davis Sir James Hardin sir Kawhi
Leonard Jason Tatum sir Rudy Gobert sir
Lucca Don Cheech sir Dame Lillard and
Sir Gerald beets and replacements for
the injured Kevin of Durant and the
vanquished Yanis attenti combo will be
nicola
yo kitsch yeah house Nuggets we did it
and finally at point guard the
undersized and often controversial but
incredibly savvy so Chris Paul are you
kidding me I know many of you are
unhappy and feeling a sense of snobbery
so where is this big battle supposed to
take place I say we draw them into the
mountains the Denver Highlands Denver I
think we should all fight for the purple
and gold I mean what better place for
such a grand super house I could never
wear those colors we should fight for
Houston no house better represents the
modern game the cutting edge of battle
strategy no there's no way that I'm
doing that we're not going to any of
those places the location of the battle
has already been chosen it will take
place at a house that everyone can agree
on a place where we can minimize
collateral because the Fanning's are
sparse and already stuck in the past a
house with a history of defense but most
importantly a place whose market
viability I'm interested in testing
tonight we ride
for Seattle
[Music]
then our enemy doesn't tire they don't
manage their loads their fundamentals
are perfect and they don't get
distracted by social media Ravens expect
relentless hand jacking and ruthless
physicality not exactly your best pump
up speech there doc how much practice
time do we have our scouts say they'll
be here before dome Ruby this cluster
they're all masters of the positions so
we go position this it'll confuse them
we're gonna have to be hyper efficient
attack the rim or stay back behind the
arc
Rangers let them fly from deep early
it'll force them to respect our spacing
yes I will hit them with a barrage of
step backs and my passing ability will
make them go wow I've never seen this
from a big man now make sure to come up
with some wily [ __ ] that will get
them technical fouls right
you tell the refs the minute you see
what other tunic's come on touch we'll
need every edge we could get against the
dream team
we could try going to three and force
them into a long game of zones no 90s
rules that would be a legal defense
crazy idea here but we could go small
Mike no look we have the talent we have
the skills and we have the strategy but
the reason I know we will prevail
is that we've got the ultimate weapon
analytics no you oh yeah no I've got
this we go right for the heart you take
sir Jordan one on one and push his ass
around if he falls they break you want
to prove you on the goat this is your
chance yeah yeah nope no problem I mean
it's just Michael Jordan right you know
what you were excuse me for a second I
actually have to take my talents to the
chamber pot oh thanks he's got this
hello everyone welcome to the first ever
meeting of the Order of the all-seeing
eye now of course by I I mean me I am
all see in case you didn't know I'm a
genius I invited you all here not
because we're friends but because we are
part of a spiritual house one built
around our shared hatred of a common
enemy
playing defense Oh guys Terry Kevin to
run no guys no you were all here as
victims of great snobbery excluded from
all realm teams harassed by ignorant
families chastised by Analytics blog
boys living in their parents dungeons
but let us wallow no longer in the
backcourt of despair for the shot clock
on our slander near zero where I have a
dream a vision of a realm with no haters
no hot takes and no Ravan trolls sowing
the seeds of disunity realm where we can
just play basketball in peace but first
we must destroy that which stands in our
way the mediator but isn't the media
devil too powerful what's your plan
Kyrie doesn't need a plan draymond he's
an artist he improvises I'm an artist
Kevin you never let me do what I want
yes I did I left so that you could take
whatever stupid shots you please this
group's gonna destroy itself before it
destroys the media Dale well then we
better get started follow me
hey you went you to bench feeling heated
down from his poster boy over the booze
of the crowd and the whistles they all
heard his famous cry you can get two
shots when a soft night flops but a poor
will never lie
poor she'd get bleed or a refs play
death that a poor will never lie that
was actually quite good damn yeah for a
night Wow yeah you're for a musician is
not great but for a night it's pretty
legit now all the Depot whoo he's good
for a bar like oh yeah oh my god when
you played thingamajig it's in the math
singer oh my god oh yeah yeah his voice
is so good it makes my arms blush
alright well if the realm is ending
tomorrow I've got some things to take
care of James you should get some rest
you're going to bed something like that
what was that about he's going to a
brothel
what in seven house was that I'll tell
you for Brooklyn house Nets held from
Jersey but the families were few so the
Lords of house Nets attempted a rebrand
they designed a new court new tunics
armor and a new mascot but some thought
this new mascot was just too cool that
the realm wasn't ready for something so
totally radical swamp dragons that's a
myth is this another one of your
conspiracy theories see for yourself
hey Kairi what's up back yeah you
brought some cool dudes what's up dudes
I hear you guys want to totally wreck
the media I'm down I'm sure that kind of
frustration in front of sir Jordan like
blood in the water
Oh looks like we've got a Jordan expert
over here you could say that Kobe I
figured I could be of some service great
you want to help us defeat Jordan but
you've always worshipped him I he
inspired me but I kneeled to no man I
serve the good of the realm you must
continue to move the game forward King
James you are my legacy those Knights in
there they are are lazy i sense doubt
look I know I have the size the skill
the power but this is Serge Orden I mean
the guy scored 38 points in the finals
when he had the plague
yes he's a killer and defeat him one
must become a killer
what I cut away all your distractions
cut away self-doubt insecurity once you
have removed all that does not serve you
in battle you've found your mom before
I'm I'm sorry I I don't think I
understand
I'm saying you need to shave your head
it's a shirt the world is going to end
tomorrow and I don't even know how to be
God I heard that our world was made when
the gods smashed two universes together
that's why it doesn't make much sense
you know LeBron what happened to you so
what you think looks good finally okay
whew because I just saved off like
40,000 gold worth of hair potions what
are you seven hells
they're here
halt
sir Jordan end this now before you
embarrass yourself
wait what are you all doing here it's
not safe it is now for how Sun Kings
will defend the realm
what's a Sun King we are newly formed
super house comprised of the best nights
from house sons and house Kings alone we
wallow in eternal mediocrity but
together we stand toe-to-toe with anyone
you should leave now before it's too
late
the dream team will be here any minute
well then son Kings ready yourselves
guys guys I can't watch you get
slaughtered let me join you we don't
need you we have the under-18 and who
was the guy we took over Luka Jared
Jackson Alden Bagley Marvins Bagley yes
[Music]
Sun Kings flame your balls what I'm not
gonna say it Sun kings
well there goes eight easy wins yes I
would absolutely take Jahlil Okafor over
Ben Simmons um can we talk about how
we're being attacked by Russell
Westbrook right now huh Russ attack in
the media what else is new
come on he shoots 20% from the outside
wouldn't be too concerned I don't care
about the numbers I mean he's got that
killer instinct I would have taken a
fire dragon
[Music]
all right I have a little pump up speech
I prepared you know what actually guys
I'd be showing you all short if I read
from the [ __ ] so I'm gonna go straight
from the heart if you also believe the
old heads our enemy hails from an era
far superior to our own they are Slayers
of Giants augers and Dragons untouchable
immortal they are the gods of this game
and we should just get on our knees and
thank them for the rights to live in the
shadow but against the hollow ghosts of
the past the future is the it's Colonel
underdog today we fight with the wind at
our backs and those gusts howl with the
cries of legendary Knights yet unborn
now I could go on but all generation
doesn't have the attention span for the
so let's go out there and show them what
efficient basketball looks like my
fellow gods of tomorrow we are the dream
teams night
the red dream team welcome to the Euro
step where's the bathroom
do all trophy-sized my hair
my saying this is the craziest battle
I've ever seen
he's mine hole abroad how I've waited
for this take it in because this is your
last
good farmer
spare some wine for your goat
I'll go don't drink wine I mean me King
James the now undisputed greatest knight
of all time nobody's better than Michael
Jordan well you know I defeated him save
the realm no big deal okay is that the
Bron James Shaw Reese what's he won just
a little celebratory wine is all he says
he's better than Sir Jordan it's true
actually oh come on
Jordan's got six rings Jordan tequila
never lost the final oh he says he beat
him it's a big battle
okay well Jordans like 60 so gives a
[ __ ] well actually he was in his prime
because he used magic sold our shards on
the dream team and have you not heard of
any of this now we'll check your
highlight Ravens haven't gotten any what
about your local sports crier nope no
newsa nothing social media Ravens have
been down for a while too wait so you're
telling me we just had the biggest most
epic battle in the history of the realm
and nobody heard about it
guess not what
oh now this is great finally we can just
play basketball no blog boys around to
criticize us we've got no haters in the
stands yeah it's um it's nice boring
though realm officials everyone just be
cool
Kairi stork I know these dudes LeBron
what have you done you saved the realm i
liberated it
you didn't have to burn it all down you
destroyed everything the stats the
history the stories gossip the ignorant
critiques the unfounded trade rumors
through all I've done for you I finally
beat sir Jordan and now there's no media
dam to talk about it ah so that's what
this is about that I've spoiled your
coronation ceremony don't be fooled Sir
Anthony his whole selfless teammate act
is just that an axe behind those corny
dad jokes is an insatiable appetite for
adoration Perry you must understand that
with the media Dell in shambles there is
nobody to generate interest in our
battles our ratings are dim our economy
is failing every second defending isn't
obsessing on Ben's image trade rumors or
r.j. Barrett's Progress is one they are
spending exploring other passions like
science philosophy or even worse
spending time with their families what
can I say guess I ruined something else
we're going to have to suspend you
indefinitely for this but considering
you are a star Knight we would be
willing to commute your sentence if you
and your crew of grumpy boys agreed to
rebuild the media tell you've still got
so much potential curry
don't waste it sulking here in the dark
don't tell me what to do I'm not your
sidekick anymore very well
burn down the media Dell there what
hello I have burned down a few things in
my day okay like what
how sixes Meister hinky how long have
you been down here Oh quite some time
the only thing that sustains me is
knowing that somewhere beyond those bars
JoEllen bead Ben Simmons and I assume
Jayson Tatum are now a dynasty tell me
how many championships have we won Oh
what I'd give for the chance to show the
world I can do more than just burn
things down telling me about its
destruction is the easy part
any cynic can tear things down and call
themselves a genius but it takes a true
visionary to actually improve things to
build a better world that's the part I
was really looking forward to that's the
real challenge so now you want us to
just rebuild this place what about your
whole rant about haters I gotta say
being in the dungeon for almost a day it
really changed me I realized the haters
are what fuel us without conflict there
is no story and all realm is as much
about the stories as the battles
themselves
okay well also if we don't rebuild this
we won't be rich anymore I have to get
real jobs so what do we do Russ you
throw up bricks from a distance
Kevin collect all your burners and start
repopulating the Raven tree draymond
you're the guy on the construction site
that yells at everybody Jimmy you're
also that guy cookie you'll handle the
engineering and blueprints would why me
because you've got vast experience with
technicals swamp dragon you'll be doing
the welding and Melo you're on the bench
oh come on
I'm good again
I gotta say Kyrie I'm impressed it's a
tap to mediate their all time there's
one last thing to do all the books and
histories of this realm were destroyed
in the fire
they must be rewritten let the truth
fill these books
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of boleros we are
here to bestow upon King James the most
exalted title of goat of goats for he
hath let his Knights to victory against
the foe once believed unbeatable the
dream team
in doing so he defeated prime Michael
Jordan earning him the title of the
greatest knight of all time hashtag wash
King thank you everyone but the day
isn't really about me it's about my
teammates it's about all the legends who
came before me
of course the Fanning's the media del
masters and the future Coates who may
one day take this crown for me thank you
now before we officially crowned King
James are there any objections I mean
you could make the case LeBron got lucky
you know yeah I mean I was at the battle
and don't get me wrong the bran was
incredible but it was only one battle
best-of-seven put my money on Jordan
what I don't know I got a disagree with
you Chuck I think now that these guys
finally beat the dream team I think
that's all the evidence I need to say
that the goat it's gotta be Tatum right
it's gotta be table what Jason Tatum has
everyone gone mad where's Nick right
I think the dragon got him now hold on
everyone I am lucky enough to witness
King James's greatness night in and
night out what he does at his age is
truly unprecedented thank you that being
said what one could argue he's not even
the best knight on his own team well now
hold on the numbers cannot be denied I
have amassed the most points of any
knight in history
also six rings I am the goat I would
kick LeBrons
us this debate is over
I am the goat but let me ask you this
what does the word goat mean to you
anyway what makes a goat is it the Rings
is it the stats is it the style no it's
the story there's nothing more powerful
than a good story and who has a better
story
then Paul Pierce what Paul Pierce not
only has a championship ring and was a
10 time all-star but he did it all after
being stabbed he once hit a game-winning
bank shot and when asked if he called
Bank he said I called gang
a crippled man who became the most
interesting Meister in the media Dell
when he had the courage say he was
better than Dwyane Wade he's right he's
right about something that shot over al
Harrington was all time to Paul Pierce
the true goat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you